new information tonight on the fallout
from the release of that inspector
general's report here is chief
intelligence correspondent catherine
herridge at least two Trump campaign
aides that pled guilty to lying to
federal agents a violation of 18 USC a
thousand in one the inspector general's
report found FBI personnel on the
Clinton email case dismissed the idea
that anyone would be prosecuted for
misleading investigators an unidentified
agent grilled a Hillary Clinton aide
over access to a secure facility at
Clinton's New York home known as ask if
that is supposed to be off-limits
without a security clearance agent one
awesome light is blank off went from
never inside the skiff at rest to looked
in when it was being constructed to
remove the trash twice to troubleshot
the secure fax with HRC a couple of
times to every time there was a secure
fax I did it with HRC ridiculous FBI
employee would be funny if he was the
only guy charged in this deal agent one
I know for a thousand and one even if he
said the truth and didn't have a
clearance when handling the secure fax
ain't no one gonna do blank the
Inspector General also takes on
Clinton's assertion the fact is nothing
that I sent or received was marked
classified and nothing has been
demonstrated to contradict that Fox News
first reported that a handful of Clinton
emails contain classified markings the C
stands for confidential the least
sensitive in her July 2016 FBI interview
Clinton repeatedly speculated it was a
reference to paragraphs ranked in
alphabetical order witnesses told the IG
her claim that she did not understand
the significance of the CE Marking
strain credulity agent one stated I
filed that in the bucket of hard to
impossible to believe the Justice
Department Inspector General also
referred five FBI employees for
investigation for politically charged
texts revealing in its report that more
Bureau officials beyond agent Peters
Strunk an FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
exchanged anti-trump text messages after
a month of negotiations struck may not
be able to avoid answering questions
under oath much longer we have been
asking for Peter struck for quite some
time
and we've advised the department that if
they do not produce him shortly a
subpoena will be issued by me very
shortly to require him to come in and
testify a Monday inspector general
Horowitz and FBI director ray will
publicly testify before the Senate
Judiciary Committee Horowitz is expected
to defend his findings about political
bias raised expected to defend the
bureau after the reports sobering
findings Brett will follow it all
captain thank you